alright so I saw transformers 4 last
night on my 38th birthday yeah i went to
transformers age of extinction I've seen
the first three of course everyone
seeing them and the first one was fine
the second one was horrific third order
is pretty awful but with these things
that come from your childhood you have
this endless hope or at least I do this
endless hope that they're going to be
better somehow it's going to get you
back to that place when you were a kid
and you could just unadulterated Lee
love something and the first hour of the
movie I could not believe it they were
doing it it had a back story related to
the the Dinobots and dinosaurs that it
was cool and something was happening and
it felt science fictiony and it looked
cool and I was like holy cow Michael Bay
is proving me wrong he could finally do
it and then for the next six hours it
devolved into a horrible painstakingly
painful awful explosion fest that we've
come to believe about these things so
there were a couple points that I wanted
to make and then I'm gonna wrap this
thing up in a nice little bow and make
an offer to Hollywood so for some reason
Optimus Prime who was if you watch the
original transformers the cartoons he
was a great good guy in a leader who
believed in the right things Michael Bay
has turned him into a bipolar psychopath
who he has a bloodlust and wants to just
kill everybody that's just not how it
should be good guys should not be like
that that's not Optimus Prime but
forgetting that forgetting just like the
childhood part of it the product
placement in this movie was unfucking
believable a truck of bud light just it
falls over Marky Mark whatever his name
it starts drinking bud light they had
Beats Audio like it was just painful it
was painful and the whole thing was a
commercial for China because that's
really where they're trying to push this
movie so they filmed a lot of it in
China and they just want to give China
are crap China usually gives us their
crap so I guess we were flipping it on
China so maybe Michael a is really
genius the whole movie I don't know it
wasn't for kids because it's so violent
they were cursing and just it's a mess
but it's also not for a dolt because if
you have a functioning brain it's not
for you either so if you want something
that's for kids and for adults I would
recommend that you see the 1986
Transformers movie the original
generation one animation and it's
amazing and it's brilliant and it's
artistic Orson Welles plays the voice of
Unicron and it's just fan-freakin-tastic
and all the things that are wrong with
these craptastic disasters they're all
right in that movie and it was making
that Michael Bay so Michael day is the
director of these things and you can't
blame him for all of it because there
are people that write it those people
should be in jail but Michael Bay he
directs these things and they're just
these endless it's just this cacophony
of explosions and none of it makes sense
and you start thinking it makes sense
and there's an edit that doesn't make
sense and a character that doesn't make
sense if you can't really understand
what anyone's saying I don't thinking
this is America Michael day is America
we'd love to blow [ __ ] up we don't know
what we're doing we're mixed messages
we're over budget and we're just selling
crap endlessly so Michael Bay is like
the perfect metaphor for America and I
sort of admire him for that and I
understand that he could probably
destroy me very easily too so here's the
offer that I want to make to you
Hollywood I as someone that loves the
Transformers Aaron love loved what they
were at one time I will direct the next
transformers movie I think it's time
Michael Bay has had enough of this know
you guys I will direct the next
transformers movie I will do it for
minimum wage and i'll do it for i have
no idea what the budget on this thing
was let's say it was 300 million bucks
i'll do it for 3 million bucks i will
figure out a way i will direct the next
transformers movie it will be better
than all those transformers movies and
and then i will also start a class
action lawsuit against michael bay and
will have them deported with beeper okay
thanks